all right moving on i've got a bit of a
brief research review segment here where
i'm gonna talk about uh two pieces of
research that
um
made some waves you know generally got
picked up uh by the media and then got
you know
tossed around a little bit on social
media you know throwing the the links
and the headlines around so i wanted to
address these just because so many
people have been talking about them
the first one i want to cover is another
paper that's largely being attributed to
to poncer
although i wouldn't necessarily call it
a paper by poncer necessarily so
um
in a previous the most recent episode we
talked about that paper where poncer was
the lead author where they were looking
at metabolism across the lifespan
so go back to the previous episode to
get caught up to date on that particular
research review but in this case it was
the same group of researchers but poncer
was not the lead author in this case he
was the third author but a lot of people
are calling it the ponzer paper because
uh he is an author you know third author
it usually indicates a very substantial
contribution so i don't want to i don't
want to diminish that um but this is an
idea that poncer really popularized and
he's he's if there's one idea he's known
for it's the topic of this paper so
seeing his name on in the top three on
the marquee there you know a lot of
people are are calling it the ponzor
paper uh to some extent that that's
appropriate but i have seen papers in
the past just being in academic
publishing where like
you kind of know who did what on a
project and like the person who's like
lead author did like 96 of it and
everybody's calling it like someone
else's paper because they're like
the most famous person on the paper but
they're like six out of ten yeah you
know and i'm just like out of respect
for the lead author like you know let's
make sure we're given credit there but
anyway
this paper came from that big group uh
they're using that data from the
international atomic energy agency
double doubly labeled water database uh
so this paper is by caro halsey poncer
and a whole bunch of other people that
are associated with that huge group and
they've actually had quite a few papers
coming out i've seen at least three over
the last couple weeks uh utilizing this
database which is awesome because it's
this database is a really cool resource
i'm glad that people are making good use
of it
so in this particular study you know the
previous one was looking at energy
expenditure across the lifespan
this study is looking at energy
compensation so the general question
here is
if somebody increases their exercise or
their activity thermogenesis if they're
expending more energy
from physical activity are they going to
compensate and reduce other components
of energy expenditure
which really ties into poncer's
constrained energy expenditure model the
idea that you know as you increase
activity energy expenditure
you know other components of energy
expenditure such as resting energy
expenditure will get constrained to kind
of offset that to some extent
and so you mentioned that a takeaway
that a lot of people have had on the
internet is like because of this study
we now know that exercise doesn't
increase your energy expenditure yeah
that's that's a take that i've seen with
uh
alarming levels of frequency yeah so two
specific instances where i've seen this
is you know we use uh activity level
correction factors
in the macro factor diet app we're
trying to estimate your when you're just
getting started and we don't have any
data from you it's our kind of
estimation process for your starting
energy expenditure we do have a
correction factor for physical activity
and so some people have asked
why even bother you know and another
thing that's come up that i've seen is
uh you know just the the general
question does this mean that exercise is
useless in a weight loss program
now with this particular paper they used
the
data from that big data set in this case
they had
over 1700 participants because they
could only use data where they had the
the doubly labeled water information for
total daily energy expenditure but they
also had resting energy expenditure
measured via indirect calorimetry so
they didn't have that for every single
individual in this data set uh you know
but the last paper had like 6 000
participants or something like that in
this case we're talking about 1700 which
is more than your typical caffeine study
for sure yeah you know exercise science
we're usually looking at like 20 or 30
people so
1700 is if we're lucky if if we're lucky
yes so 1700 is a lie
get eight subjects just say like yeah
it's a pilot study yeah that's fine
um
and so what what they found here was
that uh
the average energy compensation that was
observed in this data set
on average was about 28
and so what that means is you know when
people tried to you know
increase their
uh activity energy expenditure
or increase their energy expenditure via
physical activity um only about 72
percent of those extra calories really
got added on to the total daily energy
expenditure so if they tried to increase
their energy expenditure by increasing
uh 100 calories of physical activity
their total daily energy expenditure
would only go up by about 72 rather than
100. so
i i just need to fact check something
real quick sure
72 percent is a is a different number
than zero percent right
traditionally okay yeah so basically
what that indicates again that's the
average there so
what that tells us is you know people
who are increasing their physical
activity trying to burn some extra
calories they think they're increasing
it by 100 calories but in reality it's
only going up by
what i say about 72 because there's this
28 that's being compensated by reducing
things like resting energy expenditure
either from basal energy expenditure or
potentially a contribution from
non-exercise activity as well so
reducing those basal processes reducing
non-exercise activity those could be
contributing to this compensation effect
now the effects were similar for males
and females they were similar for young
participants and old participants but
they did seem to to differ based on body
composition so
people that were in the 10th percentile
of the bmi distribution compensated to a
magnitude of about 27 28
but when they looked at the 90th
percentile there was a compensation of
about 49
uh that's a pretty drastic difference
going from the people with lower body
weight to the people with higher body
weight and so definitely that would
reinforce this concept that people who
are on the higher end of the bmi
spectrum have a greater degree of
compensation so when they tried to
increase their energy expenditure
through 100 calories of physical
activity total daily energy expenditure
only went up by about half that rather
than the entire hundred calories just as
a representative example so the one
thing that this paper cannot answer due
to the observational nature is
uh what's going on there
is it the idea that as you increase
adiposity and accumulate more weight and
more body fat does that increase
compensation in a causative way or is it
more likely
that people who compensate more
are more predisposed to accumulating
more body weight and body fat across the
lifetime
since it's observational we can't say
which comes first in that kind of
causative change and we also can't rule
out the possibility that something
completely different is kind of
contributing there but my if i had to
guess uh i think it's more likely
that individuals who have a high degree
of compensation are probably more
predisposed to accumulating more body
fat over time if i had to
guess
that would be where my money is at but
again with an observational study like
this we can't really say necessarily
which one comes first
yeah so this is purely anecdotal i
wouldn't be surprised if it's a little
bit of both though yeah um
like as someone who has been
quite large and also considerably
smaller
my my experience has been that
uh just being like wiped out from
exercise training whatever
did affect me less when i weighed less
and i think part of that is just simply
like
dude if you got more of yourself that
you need to get up off the couch it's a
little bit harder to get up off the
couch yeah um
so yeah i mean i i
obviously wasn't doing like w labeled
water experiments on myself for
though continuously for the last 15
years
but i i
i think you are
correct
that it it is more that people who are
predisposed to be larger probably do
just inherently have larger
compensations but i wouldn't be
surprised if if it's a little of column
a and a little of column b just based on
my own experience yeah totally possible
so hopefully uh you know what we'll get
to the bottom of that in the future with
more research so
now you're totally caught up to speed on
the whole uh
series of papers that have really caught
the attention of the fitness industry
out of that group and again the
important thing to emphasize here the
compensation was not a hundred percent
it is it is not the case that you know
you would look at this paper look at the
results and say oh i guess exercise
doesn't increase total daily energy
expenditure that really has been one of
one of the more confusing series of
takes that i've that i've seen on social
media probably ever
honestly wow
no like if you've been alive in the
world
ever and used your eyes it should be
clear that exercising a lot does
increase the amount of calories you burn
to some degree yeah you know like i mean
yeah if you if you've been on this earth
for long enough to generate uh
observations
that should that should be painfully
obvious
that that is a more painful take to me
than just about anything i've ever seen
yeah and i mean the thing that i thought
of is like if you've ever hung out with
an endurance athlete during a really
high volume stretch of their training
they eat a bagel every 20 minutes like
they are just consuming calories
throughout the day non-stop
and uh notoriously pretty slim endurance
athletes
it's it's
a pretty notable observation when you're
like dude do you ever stop eating and
it's like yeah i ran like 40 miles this
week i'm pretty hungry you know that is
that even a high volume for endurance
athletes
that would be a high volume for like a a
recreational runner the the pros are
typically
i mean it depends what distance you're
talking about but generally 70 plus
sometimes top and 100 that's a lot
uh all right so the other
study that i wanted to mention here my
headline is the fake news vilification
of hot dogs from a state up north uh so
this is research coming out of michigan
and we're not very fond of those those
individuals during football season
because this is a strong ohio state
football podcast we have not locked down
that sponsorship yet but we are working
diligently
so this is a study out of the university
of michigan and it caught a lot of
headlines because the the kind of
easy takeaway uh was that a hot dog
reduces uh your healthy lifespan by like
36 minutes give or take
um
and so first of all i want us to accept
that at face value and kind of suspend
any skepticism we might have
so
if one hot dog reduces your healthy
lifespan by 36 minutes
and you said you know what i don't care
i really like hot dogs i'm gonna eat for
a week for my entire life because it
just means a lot to me you know
so unless i messed up my numbers i'm
pretty certain that
four hot dogs a week at 36 minutes a pop
if you continue that habit for 70 years
of your life you would lose one year on
the back end
seems like a not that bad of a trade-off
to me personally i mean i don't eat hot
dogs anymore due to my path to
enlightenment
but uh
yeah i mean that that's not as
catastrophic when you start to actually
put some numbers to it and say oh that
that's not particularly scary yeah uh
now
that's if we suspend our skepticism i'm
just going to be honest i have like a
personal bias here with this type of
thing i just really dislike metrics that
lack face validity like because i don't
think you would actually
walk up to somebody
in the field of nutrition to say like do
you
truly believe this statement if you eat
a hot dog it reduces your lifespan by 36
minutes i i don't actually believe
anyone would say i actually believe that
in a literal way
and so my i my perspective is you know
we're trying to i assume quantify these
things to make them more tangible but if
we don't actually believe that tangible
quantification i i just don't see why we
really bother with these things i don't
think it's particularly
helpful or useful but that's my personal
opinion i'm sure a lot of really smart
folks disagree with me on that um but i
looked into the paper uh the scoring
system for how we arrive at this seemed
a little bit opaque to me so i dug a
little deeper and found a dissertation
document by one of the authors
of this paper
and within the dissertation document if
you've ever opened up a dissertation
they're long and they have like 70
tables in them you know it's like all
this like the paper that results from it
is like the highlight reel you know the
dissertation is like usually like 200
pages 36 appendices it's long so there's
all the details in there about how the
scoring system works a couple things
that jumped out to me can i just throw
out a really hot take sure so this is
adjacent to something we've talked about
on the podcast before how uh
there's just there's so many
low impact publications that come out
every year just due to like publisher
parish type pressures
i actually kind of think that
dissertations rock and that's how like
most research should be done
you know just pump out like one
dissertation quality thing per year boom
great and like obviously that wouldn't
make sense for an individual to do now
one because journals wouldn't publish it
word count limits etc uh and two because
you know even if you have one high
impact pub a year generally that's going
to be looked
uh poorly upon if people you're
competing against have
15 lower impact pubs
uh but i i think in a perfect world
most most research documents would look
a lot more like theses or dissertations
just because
like you're describing there uh
they're so much more thorough
you know uh
oftentimes when you're reading an
individual paper you will have questions
after you read the methods section which
should not be the case like the
theoretical purpose of a method section
is if someone wanted to perfectly
replicate your study they could and like
that's kind of rare i think yeah for for
a method section to actually be that
thorough you almost always see that in
dissertations um and then often like
there's a logical flow to them like they
might include two three four experiments
that all build on each other so you can
kind of see how an idea develops and
uh multiple layers of evidence
supporting whatever concept it is so i
i think in a perfect world that's how
most science would be done and
communicated um
anyway you mentioned dissertations i
just wanted to slide that in there
uh you can keep going all right we'll do
so
so yeah um
basically uh i i took a quick look at
the scoring system a couple things that
jumped out to me were
it was pretty punitive for sodium
and it was a little bit punitive for red
meat as well
and those are kind of those things where
when you start to look at how these
quantifications work
they peel away a lot of the context of
the specific food item and the overall
construction of the diet they try to
boil it down to kind of basic
contributing factors and sometimes it
it's not super helpful to do that you
know so like
if you have a high sodium food in the
context of a diet that isn't
particularly high in sodium or you know
you're an exerciser you have a lot of
sweat loss or you're not particularly
sodium sensitive when it comes to your
blood pressure response to diet like
some of these things start to really
break down in more nuanced applications
so anyway you know these types of
scoring systems i don't really know if i
support the general premise uh
and even if you do they tend to get
pretty overly reductionist and you run
into situations where some foods can
have kind of
unexpected
results within the scoring system based
on their various components
so
one of the other things that jumped out
to me here is i'm not really fond of the
concept of treating risks as these like
perfectly linear things where you do it
once and your lifespan shortens you do
it twice your lifespan shortens more i
mean
at the end of the day uh you know we're
talking about probability here you know
you could do a something that is
carcinogenic
and
if you do that for your entire lifespan
and never end up developing cancer as a
result of that behavior
your lifespan did not shorten due to
that thing
despite the fact that it is known to be
carcinogenic you know i mean you'd want
to avoid that if possible but i i don't
know if if i like
this approach this is probably how like
actuary tables work right
but um
yeah if you play russian roulette six
consecutive times with a single revolver
you will die but
you don't become one sixth dead exactly
yeah yeah so uh it's something to keep
in mind is like this this whole approach
to the scoring system and the the way
it's treated as this kind of perfectly
linear thing in the headlines i'm not
super fond of now this sounds super
critical i don't want to just like bash
the paper because it is work that is
done well
um you know with people like this stuff
and this is a suitable way to do
nutrition uh kind of like
epidemiological nutrition science so
this is just me being uh a little bit
contrarian just because you see these
headlines that people run away with and
you're like i understand the headline
and where it comes from but i don't
believe that anyone actually believes
that so if you're curious about why you
kept seeing those headlines that's
pretty much um where this comes from but
this particular paper did not introduce
new
evidence you know new empirical evidence
about risks associated with actually
consuming hot dogs they basically said
hot dog okay we've got uh you know uh
super refined bread we've got high
sodium we've got processed meat check
check check 36 minutes so that's where
this came from and i don't put a whole
lot of stock i mean hot dog is not a
particularly healthful food we knew that
before this study we know that after the
36 minute component is
very arbitrary in my opinion
now there was an interesting aspect of
this paper that looked at the
environmental impact of foods and it did
the same kind of approach where i tried
to assign a score you know use some
scoring systems to talk about how
choosing a particular food might impact
the environment now i don't have the
skill set to really assess
that type of scoring system i'm not an
environmental scientist but an important
thing to note is that these authors are
environmental scientists part of me you
know if you look at the paper and say
you know what the health and nutrition
stuff let's table that for a moment and
i just want to look at the environmental
impact stuff
i would have to assume
that the environmental impact stuff is
potentially a little bit more
uh rigorous and robust and applicable
than the nutrition side because this phd
was done in environmental health
sciences um so that was that part of the
paper was probably more squarely within
their wheelhouse rather than uh
specifically looking at like nutritional
science or something like that
i'm just guessing but um it is it was an
interesting paper to look at some of the
environment-related ramifications of
choosing a variety of different foods so
if you're interested in that it's a cool
paper for that like i said i don't have
the skill set to really assess
those environmental scores but that is a
rundown of the papers that have been in
the headlines